merci benoît cette information si elle
était confirmée ne peut qu'accentuer la
crainte des civils qu'ils soient hutu
tutsi
surtout dans les villages où l'armée
française ne peut pas se rendre il reste
à la merci des incursions de soldats ou
de miliciens
cette peur nous envoyés spéciaux
isabelle staes et pascal pons ont pu
l'observer en sillonnant une région où
tout lorsqu'on s'enfonçant territoire où
tous les barrages jalonnent les pistes
les militaires français avaient demandé
qu'il soit retiré
la consigne n'a pas été suivie des
barrages tenus par des civils hutus de
simples villageois qui s'autorisent
ainsi à contrôler les identités
on appelle ça la défense civile
ceux là sont des gendarmes hutus qui
arrive de kigali pas de problème mieux
vaut ne pas être tout 6 mai circulent
t-il encore dans ce secteur leurs
cadavres s'entassent et à ces barrages
il y encore peu de temps pour qu'il n'y
a pas eu notamment des membres de la
sphère et après comme ça la peur des
rebelles frisent parfois l'irrationnel
de kilomètres plus loin un autre barrage
nos passeports sont cette fois-ci
contrôle et on nous soupçonne soudain de
travailler pour le svr
le gasoil
ici on nous assure que le simple citoyen
tout ici n'est pas inquiété très vite au
jugé dans la paroisse voisine
les soeurs de saint françois d'assise
vif encadraient de militaire la peur là
aussi des rebelles aux côtés de sor
teresa belge une majorité de
nous avons eu faire qu'ils allaient
venir des essuie de l'iaaf à ce qu'ils
allaient nous attaquer par le lac
oui on a eu longtemps qu'ils allaient
attaquer qui pouvaient surgir la nuit
mais maintenant que les français sont là
nous n'avons plus faire ils vont se
risquer dans la paroisse quelques
orphelins leurs parents sur victimes du
fpr est ce à cause des militaires
omniprésent ici en tout cas on tente de
justifier la colère des buttes ou la
colère a déposé maintenant avec la môle
déside ans
et pour tous ceux qui tout le mal qu'il
a fait à notre demande on nous présente
un groupe de novices tutsi
non
bon
oui
en territoire où tout même dans une
paroisse on n'ose plus dire que l'on est
tout petit le